musique comme musicienne
fait sensuelle ouvert
bonjour c'est tony nous en écouter
formes musique est juste après je vous
explique le pourquoi du comment de cette
chanson
[Musique]
en famille
ça - k j'achète répit - commencé
en blanche noire aura en tout comme un
pet course est même si vos marchés
attendent le monde entier
en famille
[Musique]
oui mais ça joue et toutes conditions tu
-
encrés de sort
dis-moi
besoin
m
vos mains
piano battons
nous sommes est
point
[Musique]
et comme les ciel très sensuelle ban
à
je sais
moi
dr
[Musique]
enfant mais si en mai
1966 trichot 10 10 dans votre console et
la
mairie
de gaillac scellé
- et
mais c'est
cb nous
mbokani
en quoi
besson
et c'est le coeur vous mélangez voix
[Musique]
pianissimo mais où l'autre
faux messies gsm
en
c'est ça
ses côtés
[Musique]
voilà
c'est
[Musique]
à
m
ou pas
et
[Musique]
c'est qu'en mai
je sais
[Musique]
ans
format
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au magicien
[Musique]
musicienne
j'ai
[Musique]
for music est une composition de chico
siméon et en fait j'ai eu envie de
relier la femme à tout ce qui fait le
solfège et la musique donc la femme
ronde
pourrait trouver un autre sens mais
c'est la ronde
la blanche la noire toutes ces choses
qui sont liaison entre le solfège et la
musique et la chanson dix enfants
musique en musicienne en magicienne
c'est à dire que tout s'est lié pour moi
je suis à la recherche de cette femme je
pense l'avoir trouvé
je suis un musicien ma quête d'absolu
est autour de la musique pour trouver
une femme musique c'est vraiment la
réussite absolue dans ma quête je vous
donne rendez vous prochainement je ne
suis pas quel événement je sais pas pour
quel spectacle mais on se revoit bientôt
sur les réseaux sociaux sur les scènes
sous les essieux vos écrans à bientôt
en magicien